the dallas cowboys we saw a little jerry
jones at the top talking about being
vaccinated here is jerry jones talking
about the selection the cowboys worked
hard to earn last year 10th overall what
are they gonna do here's jerry
i think that
we've got a good chance to
have a top defensive player
the top or one of the top be there
at 10. i think the real thing to do is
uh
don't be don't be stupid
over
uh your needs
just just talk don't be ridiculous
that's uh
that's some sage advice don't be stupid
over your needs yeah
the teams will say best available best
available we're taking the best
available your best available assessment
is always driven by your needs and the
cowboys have clear needs on defense but
hey chris they also need to start
thinking about refilling some of those
spots on the offense sure because that
wall is crumbling it i mean it is but
you know there's still a lot of money
and assets poured into that wall and i i
don't know if it's time to like
necessarily
start wasting or i don't want to say
waste but going to the 10th pick of the
draft to replenish the o-line i don't
think it's that time yet yeah they got
to start thinking about retooling it
making it younger and they can do that
in some of the later rounds in the draft
but i mean they need a difference maker
to you know for for what jerry's saying
yeah they need they need the best
defensive player in the draft whoever
they see fit to be that guy you know
they're a team i do sit there and look
at and at number 10 listen yeah i i
mocked him you know patrick certain
right we certainly could see that the
best defensive player in the draft is
jalen phillips is the defensive end from
miami will they take him you know with
the concussion history and all that i
mean he's a cowboys type of guy you know
big freaky you know super stud kind of
human being that would make sense but
uh i don't know there's risk there and
that's that's gonna be you know
something to watch for with that 10th
pick on on thursday night
we'll talk about the pft mock draft in
less than an hour now
certain is gone when the cowboys pick
under that formulation so
spoiler alert it may not be a defensive
player at all for the dallas cowboys but
we shall see
uh as we will with all the other picks
obviously here's more from jerry jones
go ahead go ahead i was gonna say you
know you gotta balance you know to two
to the the best player available or
needs or something like that too
you know at some point though there has
to be a spot where
okay hey this is the best player
available but we're
plentiful at this position right and
then it makes no sense like i would use
hey i'll use the green bay packers as
that example they signed preston smith
as a darius smith in free agency a few
years ago then they had a top 10 pick
and they drafted rashaan gary who plays
the same position the other two guys do
and now he's really doesn't have a role
on the football team so that's where you
can't always just go we're going to take
best player available you have to have
some balance about what's on your roster
and your team you know to make sure that
that guy can you know truly capitalize
on helping your team and be the best he
can be too
i think you're absolutely right and to
the extent that these teams get so
blindly tied to their boards that they
they must take that next name that pops
up no matter what position he plays you
aren't crafting your board with your
knees no mind and i just think you have
to craft your board with your needs in
mind this is your opportunity to fill
those needs you've already had free
agency whatever needs you have left
unless you're going to work a trade or
somebody's going to get unexpectedly cut
and they're going to fall into your laps
or you're going to get some undrafted
free agent or some guy who just happens
to be hanging around and all of a sudden
he works out this is your chance to
address the needs that you have now one
need the cowboys don't have is pass
catcher but there's been a lot of talk
lately about jerry jones being
infatuated with florida tight end kyle
pitts first of all join the club yeah
second of all jerry spoke yesterday
about the
supposed kyle pitts infatuation here's
the question and then jerry's answer
when reports come out say you're
infatuated with a guy like pitts
uh
is that legitimate or do you just like
the gentleman huh not legitimate
but when i say it i am
anybody in this draft is
impressed
okay probably an exaggeration is
fascinating i may have used the word
myself
but the point is it's uh it's a
distortion
uh for this draft and where we are there
it implies something that's just not the
case
we're not going to go in there and uh
spend
uh uh
spend inordinate
collateral or value
to maneuver up there so that we can get
pit
or pits as the case may be did you hear
stephen jones kind of let out an audible
oh yeah oh god i did not
kill the mic like don't ask this guy
about him
yeah when he started into that
explanation but hey i think jerry did a
good job of not tipping their hand and
it ain't going to matter unless they're
moving up to four
it's all academic kyle pitts is most
likely not going to be lingering on the
board when the cowboys pick at number 10
or
789 range where they would trade up a
few spots and they don't
need they just don't need him and this
is where we get into best available
versus need you've got far greater
requirements that you need that's right
to be a competitive football team in
2021 yeah that's right and i mean you
know again a team with as many holes as
they have right now especially on the
defensive side i mean are we really
gonna trade away picks to move up to
like like what you're saying first off i
mean you'd really realistically have to
move up to four because you know you got
you got to ensure you know four or five
or six pits that's a good chance is
going to one of those three teams right
there i mean i'd be shocked if he got
out of that little run of teams there
between you know the the falcons the
dolphins and of course the cincinnati
bengals who were sandwiched in the
middle there so yeah i expect the
cowboys to stand pat exactly where they
are
and
you know take the best defensive player
available i think that's more of the
best way to say it best defensive player
available that's a secondary guy or a
difference maker up front and there's no
defensive tackle that's worth the number
10 pick of the draft so then it really
gets into
a numbered few you start to get into
patrick certain
jc horn with the south carolina
gamecocks right those are the two guys
that a lot of people have at the top of
the list and they they they fit that
seattle scheme it makes sense for them
to take them and then you go into okay
what's the next thing edge rusher and
that's it's a short list of people too
it's it's jalen phillips who we
mentioned earlier quitty pay
jason away you know maybe from penn
state but i don't think anybody looks at
him as being a top 10 pick so it's
really four guys in my mind it's the two
corners quitty pay and jalen phillips i
think that's their options right there
and i'll be interested to see which one
they go with
let me ask
kristen a favor can you take your finger
off the old time piano music button and
press
the graphic that we just had up of the
cowboys i have to make one observation
that photo of mike mccarthy had to be
from the day he was introduced as the
head coach of the team right cause i
think that's the last time he's been
happy
i really do but
seriously am i wrong no was that wrong
no okay you're not wrong it's been a
it's been a bumpy road for mike mccarthy
to this point certainly i mean it didn't
go
the honeymoon year did not go the way it
was supposed to there so uh yeah they
got a lot of work in front of them and
as intriguing as a kyle pitts is and all
that no i think that's kind of crazy
talk and i think jerry put it right he
was just waxing poetically about a guy
that hey quite honestly
i've never seen a tight end like like
kyle pitts especially since i've been on
this side of the business where i watch
tape and evaluate guys coming out in the
draft and all that he's special but yeah
the cowboys don't need them they got
plenty of firepower
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports